women need to take some accountability
some accountability needs to be taken
because women have the power sorry women
have the power they're the ones that
decide who has sex there's no man that
can take sex from a woman without her
permission so in that case she has got
the power the children that are being
birthed is down to that woman because if
the man wants the child and the lady
says i'm sorry mate um you know i don't
really feel up for it i'm going to
finish off my degree and all good power
to her but you're not having that child
so the woman has the power in that case
so she has to take a bit of
accountability of responsibility for who
she's sleeping within a type of
character of that man and his masculine
traits or any red flags she might have
picked up not to sleep with him to end
up in a situation in the first place and
if a girl and if a girl and if a girl
gets pregnant it's a choice she chose to
do that because because no it really is
because we have okay you're telling me
you had no idea you could get pregnant
when you could track your cycle you
could be abstinent you could choose not
to have sex on top of that you could you
have plan b the morning after pill on
top of that you have abortion if you do
get pregnant on top of that you have
adoption if you if you get pregnant you
want to have give birth to the baby and
give it up on top of that you also have
iud which is 99.5
effective you also have birth control
which is also around 99
effective on top of that you can require
the men that you sleep with where
condoms which is also
like you you have option option option
option option option option and then
you're going to say and then then you're
going to set then you're going to say
oh boo hoo i'm pregnant what the [ __ ]
okay i i completely agree
but let's not sit here and act like
every woman a has this knowledge a has
access to all these things has been
taught all these things that women don't
go without sexual desire that women
aren't a bit ditzy every there's we're
not all just okay this is 2022 they know
these things man there's a condom from
anywhere condoms free in his family
planning please a lot of people aren't
talking about
the health and sex they're not okay so
if if that's true then why is it that
the majority of abortions are from women
that make forty seven thousand dollars
or more a year one out of three women
have had them where only eight percent
of women below the poverty line have had
an abortion
no no i so i said to you i agree to what
you're saying a lot of women would make
certain but what i'm saying i'm saying
the data does not indicate that it is an
education issue exactly because it's the
most educated women that are getting the
abortions it is the most high the
highest earning women that are getting
abortion so to me that indicates that it
is a lack of responsibility and poor
choices
rather rather than education and also
the average age of first abortion is
going up it's not the majority of
abortions are girls in their late 20s
so so it's so it's to me if you're if
you're 25 and you don't know how to use
a condom i think you have bigger
problems
even i think 21 if you don't like
honestly honestly i'm kind of a bit on
the fence with this one and the reason
why i say that is because while you know
women do have pretty much
full autonomy over their body although
you could argue about my body my choice
yeah i mean you can argue about that now
because not quite in america let's say
but um
you know
they sh they would be able to detect you
know things that you know yeah they're
pregnant yeah i've tracked my cycles as
you said all all that womanly stuff
but
at the same time i think it's a little
bit not fair to kind of kind of put
everything in the woman's boat to say
that you know you have to watch the guy
you sleep with
i would also argue to the men you have
to watch
the and and not to be you know a bit
crude you have to watch the the table
the person you dive into so
so here's the problem with that a guy
can do everything right outside of
abstinence he can do everything right
and the girl can still steal the condom
there's entire reddit threads of women
talking there's entire reddit there's
entire reddit threads of women talking
about how they want to trap a man
yeah so can i just say something is this
is the thing a woman will not get
pregnant by a man she does not want to
get pregnant yes
and you know as a woman
i can like a man i can sleep with a man
and i know i'm not gonna have a child
with this man
but that's it's a root it's real life
women know when they're lying with a
certain man i want this man's child
regardless if he wants it or not
regardless of
protection and uh
birth control and whatever else like you
can track your period and it actually
works it's a it works well and that's
and that's what i'm saying when i say
it's a choice like you chose to get
pregnant it wasn't it was a decision
because you had a b c d e f g like yeah
no you're right yeah and can i just add
as well you know when you look at
certain court cases paternity cases
when you see the women speaking those
the cases themselves it's all
emotionally driven by what the man did
what them
they when they had the children the
child whatever they knew they wanted the
children they knew they wanted those the
child right so because sorry takati but
just because it didn't go on their terms
at that point it became an issue so
continue right well and we that's what
i'm saying we always bail women out of
bad decisions it's it's always there's
always a fail-safe for women and we
don't have that for men that's why men
make up the majority of homeless people
and i think the reason why they do
that's because the law just kind of
assumes that oh women are nurturers you
have the kids you have the bulk of the
responsibility if you're with a guy and
he's you know you split up with him he
was your provider we're gonna make sure
he provides and then they just take
everything from him and i feel like the
law kind of just assumes that because it
can't be bothered to actually
investigate a situation properly and
each case is so different that's why it
goes back to when i like when i think of
sex being a duty because you get his
protection and provisioning that's the
exchange
if we're being honest that's what the
exchange is he gets he gets sex on
demand and you get his resources his
provisioning and his protection
everything's transactional
but i would also argue that you know
there's a lot of children sorry
i would also argue there's a lot of
other things that women might break
bringing to the table just i mean let's
say for this discussion's sake we're
just assuming that the man is more of a
provider role and the woman's a more
stay-at-home nurturing sort of role
and
you know fair enough yeah if the if the
guy wants sex he's allowed to ask his
wife for that i think when we call it a
duty it is back to that word again it's
a little bit icky
yeah i was going to say that the court
system and the laws of the country are
still traditional but the society is
feminine is i'm sorry i'm feminist so in
that case like men will get charged more
women will get certain things but the
fact of the matter is if we are actually
living by this sort of feminist culture
where men and women are equal shouldn't
that come to the case with divorce as
well where it should be equal rather
than this sort of skewed old traditional
style which maybe was needed
maybe 50 80 100 years ago but it's not
relevant anymore can i
just say yeah yeah back to what paul was
saying before
the reason i don't like the way that the
court system works is because it
depletes a man this is what i was going
to say before but it depletes the man
and expects him to still be able to
provide and that doesn't make sense how
can a man that's depleted actually
provides
and and for me especially when there's
you've got men who look after their
families extensively children i don't
know grandparents whatever that might be
it can be very very it's a fine thread
and we've spoken about this before
mental health well-being men being able
to express themselves freely and going
back to it's point here with the
feminine society we consider women over
all men so their emotions the way they
feel about it like the word we're saying
is a bit icky
but it's about that's a feeling